a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
George Lucas created Star Wars a new
hope spawning an entire franchise of
Awesomeness decades later we're still
learning all kinds of secrets from
behind the scenes stabilize your rear
deflectors as we scan the Star Wars saga
for some stuff even the Jedi Council
didn't know number one ig-88 on tap as
part of a group of bounty hunters hired
by Darth Vader to find the Millennium
Falcon and Empire Strikes Back
IG 88 looked really intimidating but at
the same time he looked really familiar
that's because he was previously seen in
a new hope in one of the least likely of
places as a moss eisely Cantina drink
dispenser that's right the same prop
pieces used to create ig-88 s head are
also scattered behind the cantina x-bar'
r2d2 and c3po were just steps away from
becoming a couple of bickering
distilleries but ig-88 isn't the only
one with an unlucky head number two
Jango hits his head we've all seen the
Star Wars blooper of the stormtrooper
accidentally walking into a door in a
new hope George Lucas even went back to
add a sound effect of the mishap during
the DVD re-release of the original
trilogy but did you know that Lucas paid
homage to this blooper and Attack of the
Clones
after the fight between Jango Fett and
obi-wan Kenobi the Bounty Hunter can be
seen fleeing to the slave one as a young
Boba Fett is firing up its engines
during janko's hasty retreat you can see
the ships tour clipping his helmet as he
passes accompanied by an appropriate
sound effect some argue that Jango
didn't actually hit his head during this
blinking you'll miss it moment but we'd
imagine that Lucas would have closed the
door normally if he met otherwise now we
know that stormtrooper inherited his
clumsiness it's certainly not the worst
thing that happened to janko's head
though number 3 Marvel gives Star Wars a
hand phase two of the marvel cinematic
universe is filled with tributes to the
Empire Strikes Back
specifically every movie in phase two
includes a scene of a character losing
an arm Skywalker style Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige said to cinema
blend I'm obsessed with Star Wars it
didn't start out as intentional but it
became intention
number four those darn helmets I can't
think of a helmet you think that
explains what the stormtroopers are all
bad shots well that wasn't exactly in
the script
in this scene Mark Hamill was
complaining to Harrison Ford after he
thought the cameras had stopped rolling
surprisingly Lucas decided to keep the
line in the movie just be happy you
weren't wearing that Darth Vader mask
Luke number five
the force awakens gets rated we've all
seen the awesome cameos packed into the
force awakens but there are a lot more
than you may realize
including appearances by Bill Hader
Simon Pegg Ken Leung Warwick Davis and
James Bond himself Daniel Craig for
those wondering Craig played the storm
trooper who was Jedi mind-trick by Rey
into setting her free there are a ton of
Game of Thrones cameos as well
we all know Brienne of Tarth actress
Gwendoline Christie plays Captain phasma
but there are plenty of other cameos
brought in from the Seven Kingdoms
Thomas brodie-sangster Jessica Henrik
mark Stanley milto Cyril Mo and Ammon
Eliot also appear in small roles
throughout the film our favorite force
awakens cameo comes in the form of the
criminal gang conjurer club fans of the
Indonesian action flicks the raid
redemption and the raid too should
recognize gay Yan ruffian Eko twice and
sus Aparri FRA Minh that's Rama and two
of his fiercest opponents from the
franchise number six star killer versus
Skywalker
dedicated Star Wars fans know that
George Lucas originally intended for the
protagonist of a series to have the last
name of star killer of course star
killer sounds a bit darker than
Skywalker's the name was changed
eventually Lucas arts could use the star
killer name of the protagonist in Star
Wars The Force Unleashed this videogame
puts you in the jackboots of Darth
Vader's secret apprentice order to
create a small rebellion against the
Empire distract the Emperor enough to be
overthrown these events actually led to
the creation of the Rebel Alliance
unfortunately most what the lore outside
of the movies and recent TV series got
thrown into the Sarlacc pit once Disney
to control the series at least JJ Abrams
brought the star killer name back to the
new Death Star we know it's technically
not a Death Star but actually a mobile
ice planet super weapon it's still just
a really really big Death Star that can
blast multiple planets of ones from
across the solar system big difference
number 7 where credit is due we all love
the iconic a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away Square
before each Star Wars film but did you
ever notice that there are no opening
credits before any of the movies in the
series the Directors Guild of America
slapped George Lucas with a hefty
$250,000 fine for not properly crediting
a director before the film even though
he wasn't the first person to do this as
a result
Lucas severed ties with the guild like
it was a Skywalker's arm ouch
number 8 Jedi Master Tupac yes you read
that right and no we're not making this
up
Rolling Stone reports the late great
Tupac Shakur auditioned to star as mace
windu in the Phantom Menace details are
a bit shaky since - pop was murdered in
September of 1996 and filming on Episode
one started nine months later
nevertheless just imagine if thug life
himself was cast as mace windu - pocket
of tossed aside his beef with the east
coast rappers and started feuding with a
Sith instead while some diehard rap fans
believe Tupac may still be alive and in
hiding there's no way that mace windu
survived that brutal electrocution and
defenestration and finally number 9 the
rasp of Leia did you ever watch The
Return of the Jedi and wonder why this
voice sounds familiar
oh yeah well surprisingly that voice was
done by the late actress Pat Welsh while
her list of film credits is short you
might recognize her for one other
prominent role et the extra-terrestrial
the voice of that adorable beer-chugging
candy eating alien is the same as the
bounty hunter disguise Leia used when
threatening to suicide bombed Jabba's
palace with a thermal detonator still as
some fans may know this isn't the only
connection between et and the Star Wars
saga thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which obscure
Star Wars fad surprised you the most